Mysterious Andorians?
A reference to unrequited love?
A return to a familiar star system?
Here are all of the Easter eggs you missed
in "Star Trek: Strange New Worlds" episode two.
The series' second episode "Children of the
Comet" begins with a log entry from Cadet Uhura.
She is still getting used to life aboard the
Enterprise and is about to attend a dinner
in the Captain's quarters.
There she meets the ship's new chief engineer,
an Andorian named Hemmer.
But Hemmer is no ordinary Andorian, the normally
blue-skinned, antennaed aliens who debuted
in the original series episode "Journey to
Babel."
Hemmer is a subspecies of Andorian known as
Aenar, who live in the frozen wastelands on
Andoria, as seen in the "Enterprise" fourth
season episode appropriately titled, "The Aenar."
When Uhura spots Hemmer chopping vegetables
she offers to assist, knowing he is visually
impaired, as Aenar are all blind.
Spock points out that Hemmer's other senses
compensate for his blindness, to which the
Aenar responds:
"Compensate?
They are superior."
It's also mentioned that the Aenar have a
form of precognition, and Spock helps demonstrate
Hemmer's telepathic abilities.
Both of these unique abilities were showcased
in the "Enterprise" three-part story that
introduced a young Aenar woman named Jhamel
and her brother Gareb, who until now were
the only Aenar ever seen on "Star Trek."
In that story, the Romulans kidnapped Gareb
and used his abilities to pilot a deadly new
drone ship in an attempt to provoke a war
between galactic powers.
During his dinner with the crew, Captain Pike
entertains with a story from his earlier years.
He was chasing down a pantsless Nausicaan
while working a security job and fell flat
on his face after tripping over the alien's
pants, phaser still in hand.
It's an incident that would apparently play
at least some role in his switch to command,
but it wasn't the last time a future Enterprise
captain would tangle with some nasty Nausicaans.
While we haven't seen Nausicaans that often,
this brutish alien race made a memorable first
impression in the "Next Generation" episode
"Tapestry."
In that story, Picard dies and meets Q in
the afterlife.
He offers him a chance to go back in time
and change his past.
In doing so, Picard revisits a violent incident
from his early days in Starfleet.
While awaiting his first orders after graduating
from Starfleet Academy, Picard and two friends
have a run-in with some Nausicaans who attempt
to cheat them in a game of dom-jot.
Defending his friend from a vicious melee,
Picard is impaled through the back by one
of the aliens, requiring him to have an artificial
heart implanted that he'd carry for the rest
of his natural life.
Thankfully, it doesn't sound like Pike's brush
with Nausicaans was quite so harrowing.
The second episode of "Strange New Worlds"
takes the Enterprise to the Persephone star system.
A planet there is endangered by a massive
comet that is due to strike its surface in
a world-ending event.
In his briefing, Spock says that the people
on the planet are a primitive race with no
way to know the threat they face and no way
to stop it.
With the people below unable to save themselves,
Pike and the crew get to work on finding a
way to divert the comet from Persephone III.
But this won't be the last time an Enterprise
crew makes a visit to Persephone.
It originally popped up the first season of
"Star Trek: The Next Generation," set nearly
a century later.
Though it wasn't Persephone III, the Enterprise
D visited the Persephone system briefly in
the episode "Too Short a Season."
In that story, Picard and his Enterprise crew
travel to Persephone V to pick up a renowned
Federation negotiator, the elderly Admiral
Mark Jameson.
From there, they warp to Mordan IV to oversee
the release of prisoners taken in a terrorist
hostage situation.
Things don't go as planned, of course.
It's revealed that Jameson himself may be
responsible for the crisis, the fallout from
another incident he was involved in decades
before.
Nurse Christine Chapel and Mr. Spock had a
brief interaction in the premiere episode,
and their encounter in "Children of the Comet"
made it clear there's some serious tension
there — at least from Chapel's side of things.
As Spock, La'an, Uhura, and Lt. Sam Kirk prepare
to beam to the surface of the comet, Chapel
inoculates them with an anti-radiation drug.
When she administers a dose to Spock, she
openly flirts with the Vulcan science officer,
though Spock doesn't seem to notice.
Uhura does, however, and mocks him later in
the episode, sarcastically referring to Chapel
as his girlfriend.
"I am a Vulcan.
We are too honest by nature."
"Your girlfriend must love that."
The sparks are, of course, a direct reference
to the original series, in which Nurse Chapel,
played then by series creator Gene Roddenberry's
wife Majel Barrett, showed an open attraction
to Spock and even got jealous of his relationship
with T'Pring.
It was in the episode "The Naked Time" that
Chapel professed her love for him, and in
"Plato's Stepchildren" they even shared a
kiss.
Though in the episode it was while they were
coerced by alien telepaths, and neither was
entirely comfortable with the encounter.
Under the influence of a love potion, Spock
himself became infatuated with Chapel in the
quasi-canonical "Star Trek: The Animated Series"
episode "Mudd's Passion."
Where "Strange New Worlds" will take their
relationship remains to be seen.
Inside the alien structure on the comet's
surface, the landing party discovers a mysterious
alien egg.
Unable to get many readings, it's up to Uhura
to decipher the inscriptions on the egg's
surface and find a way to lower the comet's
artificial shielding.
If she can't, the comet will destroy Persephone
III.
Uhura unwittingly discovers how to communicate
with the egg when she begins humming an old
Kenyan folk melody to alleviate her anxiety.
As it turns out, the comet's intelligence
communicates through musical tones.
Diehard Trekkies will recall that in the original
series, Uhura had shown an aptitude for singing,
and was seen doing so on more than one occasion.
She was most fond of a song called "Beyond
Antares," which she sang in two different
episodes, "The Conscience of the King" and
"The Changeling."
Later in "Children of the Comet," Uhura and
Spock sing together to communicate with the
intelligence, and, as "Star Trek" fans know,
this wouldn't be the last time they perform
side by side.
In the 1966 episode "Charlie X," Spock plays
a Vulcan lute while Uhura accompanies him
with her sweet voice, performing a song titled
"Oh, On the Starship Enterprise."
As the landing party works inside the comet
to alter its course, Pike and the Enterprise
find themselves confronted by an alien ship.
The beings aboard it refer to themselves as
"The Shepherds."
They warn Pike not to interfere with the comet,
which they believe is a kind of divine life-bringer.
This is a powerful starship that the Enterprise
can't compete with, so they're careful not
to anger them, but they cannot abandon the
mission to save the planet either.
When they're finally forced into a firefight,
Pike issues a command to get them out of there, barking
"Escape pattern April Omega Three!"
This is a clear reference to Robert April,
the former Enterprise captain who we met in
the "Strange New Worlds" premiere.
April became official canon in an episode
of "Star Trek: Discovery," where his name
appeared on a computer screen as part of a
list of Starfleet's most decorated captains,
alongside Pike, Jonathan Archer, Matthew Decker
from the original series episode "The Doomsday
Machine," and Philippa Georgiou.
Given that April has an escape maneuver named
after him, it's no wonder he's considered
one of the best.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Star
Trek: Strange New Worlds" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.